ابدا معك اولا الياس هذا البيان الذي صدر
عن مجلس عن عن ديوان رئاسه الوزراء
الاسرائيليه ماذا يقصد
به هو يقصد به امرين على الاقل في المدى
القريب وهو اولا الرد على الاداره
الامريكيه التي ابدت معارضتها لعمليه
عسكريه في رفع على اعتبار ان المكان مقتض
بالفلسطينيين الذين يقتلون في تلك المنطقه
واصبحت المنطقه اكثر اقتضا مع وصول مئات
الاف الفلسطينيين الذين هجروا قصرا من
المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه وتاكيد الجانب
الاسرائيلي على ان اسرائيل عاقد العزم على
القيام بعمليه عسكريه في منطقه رفح وفي
محور فيلادلفيا الواقع بين الاراضي
الفلسطينيه ومصر ومن ناحيه اخرى جمال يمكن
قراءه هذا الموقف وكانه موقف ياتي للضغط
على ال على المقاومه الفلسطينيه هي ورقه
ضغط كبيره بيد اسرائيل الان على المقاومه
الفلسطينيه من اجل تليين مواقفها في اطار
المفاوضات التي ما زالت كما يبدو مستمره
من اجل التوصل الى اتفاق لاطلاق راح
الاسرى الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في داخل
قطاع غزه وكان اسرائيل تقول بان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ليست في موقع يمكن من خلالها
ان تملي شروطها على اسرائيل وان اسرائيل
بامكانها ان تستخدم هذه الورقه كورقه ضغط
كبيره على المقاومه الفلسطينيه وعلى
الفلسطينيين انفسهم من
اجل التعجيل او تليل المواقف الفلسطينيه
فيما يتعلق بصفقه جديده لكن واضح بان
اسرائيل ابلغت الاداره الامريكيه بنيتها
هذه وابلغت ايضا الجانب المصري في نيتها
بالعمل في محور فيلادلفيا وفي م محور رفح
واضح بان ليس فقط الاداره الامريكيه هي من
تعارض عمليه كهذه بل ايضا الجانب المصري
في التقديرات العسكريه الاسرائيليه الجانب
المصري يرفض ذلك لانه يخشى من عمليه نزوح
كبيره للفلسطينيين في تلك المناطق الى
داخل الاراضي المصريه هنالك مخاوف ايضا
تعتري الجانب الامريكي من ان عمليه عسكريه
كبيره في منطقه رفح سوف تمنع تدفق
المساعدات الانسانيه بشكل سلس الى داخل
قطاع غزه على اعتبار ان معبر رفح هو
المنفذ الوحيد الان لادخال البضائع لذلك
نرى بان هنالك كما يبدو خطه اسرائيليه
للبحث عن بدائل اخرى لادخال المساعدات
الانسانيه الى القطاع وكان وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي اف جلن قد عرض هذا على مجلس
الحرب والمجلس الوزاري المصغر في
اجتماعهما الليله الماضيه وطرح اقامه
منظومه جديده يتم من خلالها ادخال
المساعدات عبر معبر كارني المنطار في شرق
قطاع غزه ومعبر ايرز بيت حنون في المناطق
الشماليه لقطاع غزه ولكن واضح بان هذه هذا
الموقف ال الاسرائيلي يعبر عن نيه مبيته
لدى الحكومه الاسرائيليه حيث ان رئيس
الوزراء قال بشكل واضح وصريح بانه اوعز
للجيش الاسرائيلي بتحضير خطه من مسارين
المسار الاول يتم من خلاله اجلاء اعداد
كبيره من الفلسطينيين كما يبدو الى
المناطق الشماليه وكذلك الاعداد لخطه
عسكريه ضخمه من اجل سحق كتائب القسام
الاربع الذي تع منطقه رفح لكن اذا ماه
الوزراء الاسرا جمال قالت لا يمكن تحقيق
اهداف الحرب في غزه والابقاء على اربع
كتائب لحماس هناك وقالت
بانه
سيتم الايعاز بخطه مزدوجه لاجلاء
الفلسطينيين وسحق كثاب حماس ايضا في خبر
عاجل لمصدر قيادي بحماس يقول للجزيره حماس
بحثت موقفها
من بحثت موقفها من اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار
مع الوسطاء بالقاهره وننتظر الرد
الاسرائيلي يعني هذا موقف حماس في هذه
اللحظات ردا على الرد الاسرائيلي الذي
بعثت به للوسطاء برفضها المحددات التي
قدمتها حماس ردا على
القطه هل هناك مخاوف من ان يقوم نتنياهو
بعمليه تهجير تحت القصف
للفلسطينيين باتجاه
رفح
جمال واضح بان اي عمليه عسكريه في في
منطقه رفح لن تتم الا بموافقه امريكيه
ومصريه ولا توجد كذلك موافقه من هذا
القبيل وهنالك ايضا نوع من التناقض في
الموقف الاسرائيلي حيال مساله اعاده
الفلسطينيين الى المناطق الشماليه اذا ما
نظرنا بدقه الى ما عرضته اسرائيل في معرض
ردها على رد حماس هي قالت بانها لن تسمح
للف الفلسطينيين بالعوده الى ديارهم الى
المناطق الشماليه في اطار المرحله الاولى
لصفقه تبادل الاسرى فهذا في يحمل نوعا من
التناقض عمليا جمال فهي تقول من ناحيه هي
لا تريد اعاده الفلسطينيين الى المناطق
الشماليه في اطار المرحله الاولى لصفقه
التبادل لكنها تقول من ناحيه اخرى بانه في
خضم اي عمليه عسكريه لن يكون هنالك من
مناص الا بنقل الفلسطينيين مره اخرى او
بعضهم الى المناطق الشماليه عبر ممر امن
ايه في قطاع غزه لذلك هذا ربما يعطينا
فكره على ان مساله العمليه العسكريه في
رفح ليست قريبه على الاقل في المدى
المنظور وليست هنالك اي موافقه امريكيه
عليها بل هنالك معارضه عربيه من جانب
الاداره الامريكيه ومن جانب مصر لذلك
يقودنا الى الاعتقاد بان هذه ربما تكون
ورقه ضغط على المقاومه الفلسطينيه لتليين
مواقفها في مساله صفقه تبادل اسر جميه
شكرا